my flash point ml e that morning
lighthouse edition what's up
good morning sir how you doing you got
your tasty breakfast in yeah
protein pancakes was delicious little
turkey bacon to go with this you know
that lighthouse edition scrambled eggs
worked on the Gordon Ramsay edition so
they're nice and creamy like I like
cooking so I'm always gonna work on
making them a little better so chef
Wright did it yeah you know we have
moments but you know I got a long way to
go to be anything in the culinary world
listen the weight of cheesecakes look
another yeah cheesecakes one of those
that's like if as long as it's decent
it's pretty good we got we've got a lot
to talk about so we can do a quick
rundown of kind of what to expect for
you guys a little little overview and
then we'll jump in so I've got this week
at bunchy we got a lot to talk about
more update one point one point four
they go fast
sandbox details finally not specific
numbers but definitely looking at some
things but what kind of rap the you know
the whole bungee feel and everything
into the tail end we also got news of a
lot of other stuff coming so yeah snazzy
game announcement a couple of them
actually one gonna care about a little
more and even Nintendo still thrown
their hat in the ring so can't say this
week didn't feel like III like hey
what's up March how you doing exactly
taste was ready it was lots a info this
week man lots of announcements well
without much further ado see if this is
gonna probably be a long point so we're
sorry it's definitely level we got one
of fans now we're going to try to act
like this is gonna be quick we hope you
guys do enjoy the discussion sometimes
they get long-winded but we hope you
guys get a kick out of them but yeah
let's jump into this week at Bungie so
iron banner is in session this is your
last 4v4 iron banner are you sad to see
it go you're ready for 66 what are these
phone calls I'm not this will be no
tears shed it's time
time to send you out to the woodshed it
was a good run we got to put you down
6v6 1.1 put four you know what I'm
looking for baby I mean honestly like I
like the fact that we'll have something
that makes it different if this is gonna
be it maybe there's a little bit more
they put to it but I have it something
that actually means iron Manor is more
than just another color we'll see yeah
absolutely yeah I'm hoping they do more
with like you know either
you know bounties or just more weapons
and make their own skin like make their
own true weapon set maybe some different
armor I don't know and then hopefully
with like mods to point O will get maybe
some specific PvP or iron banner ones
you can use stuff like that would be
cool but all that stuff down the road
yeah man so I know Dylan was working on
this update he even said yesterday heard
it's Friday morning so even Wednesday
he's like polishing it up today
f5 tomorrow so we did get it in the
first piece is the gotta go fast so when
they talked about the update for one
point one one point one point four
that's always easy to say hell did the
go fast update so speeding up a lot of
pieces of the game are you just even
those words alone so I can't excite you
a little bit absolutely as as you all
know and the way major complaints
against destiny has been these destiny
to is that it feels sluggish slow things
take long this is what we need to hear
seriously like it honestly so many good
things hopefully are coming from this
but one caveat aside is this gonna bring
people like even reading all of this
stuff do you think this is gonna be the
thing that brings people back yet or is
this kind of the way other games have
done it like you know trying to put
things in place for what's to come in
the future yeah I agree I think this is
not going to bring the masses back I
think again this is like we've always
been preaching the last couple of
flashpoints baby steps baby steps baby
steps but I think what's gonna happen is
the culmination of all those things Plus
that magical taking moment that they
kind of need has to happen all together
so basically for the people that's been
away I mean for people that's been
playing like us you know this D start
these little changes are great but once
you get a whole
all the two of these ComNet necks you
know a big expansion I don't know if
it's the you know the next one but the
one happen you know on the taken King
style one that is when I think it
hopefully comes together oh we shall see
indeed so first we check in with Senor
crucible designer Kevin Haines and
Design Lead Josh Hamrick of course Josh
and works pretty out there on Twitter
usually so definitely check it out
so first we've got the crucible playlist
that's coming so you've got iron banner
Rumble and mayhem I'm going to be
returning to destiny to with a few
twists so you've got iron banner going
66 we know that they say mayhem will
feature ninety percent fewer Nova bombs
so they're gonna ask that I'm just going
to bring them back they should never
take it away so I'm just returning we've
said that before but coming back soon
and also Rumble will add two additional
players from destiny once we got able do
you know it like though sooner rumble
can get here honestly the better because
I know they're working on the sandbox
we'll talk about that below but if they
would have had a rumble in there from
the beginning I think it would have
given them a better feel of feedback for
what the balancing should have been
absolutely so I'm glad it's coming back
just a little late but it got there it
just was like I was late to school crap
I get there so it's six to eight no one
expected eight so that's kind of it is
fitting with everything being four so
it's just a multiple of four but
apparently that's what they can do but I
mean eight on some of those maps --is
they're not huge I mean none of the maps
in this game are massive in comparison
there's no first light there's no Sky
Watch there's there's no major what is
the mode with the vehicles and Freddie
getting the name of uh what's the name
of it now you know yeah so somebody in
the cards feel free to tell ya there's
maps of that scale so if you have eight
people on these kind of medium sized
maps especially like burning shrine that
came forward mm-hmm
burn out that's that's gonna be kind of
tight like you know we got some buddies
but you probably even if you broke that
up into like nine quadrants that's
basically one person's fun on all
time so absolutely because it's
basically a big square so it's gonna be
interesting
but I also like that one because there
won't be team shotting so if you're
tired of that meta jump in there and you
can just see how you do one-on-one work
on your skills absolutely love that kind
of stuff get to go back to the you know
to the one-on-one engagements a little
bit more and like you said last
flashpoint you want just getting to test
out your primaries without the team shot
and seeing what's actually effective
huge yeah I mean I think that'll give
more more information on the balance
than the team shot at never would so
they said they were looking at a
feedback and they saw two key areas
which people have been yelling at the
top of their lungs for a while they have
been listening but they just have to its
bungees way they've get they've been
better and they've been more transparent
but they still have to take everything
in trying to do their analysis work on
some changes have something in the
pipeline then they'll let us know what
we said like six months ago but it shows
you but I mean they agree they said time
to kill and team shotting so i set our
sights on reworking systems mechanics
and values to tackle these two areas
first question does this mean you're
going to change time to kill do you
watch it time to kill to be quicker
personally before I even get into this
what do you think um good question I'm
gonna say yes is I think on the way I
look at it right now because things are
so slow I think that certain things
while they're effective I don't
necessarily feel they're powerful and um
again because they're not as powerful
that I think also encourages the
grouping up the team shining because
that's effective that that's when the
time to kill is super high right you're
like oh yeah now we just gotta be
careful because we don't want to get too
ridiculous you know I'm saying but at
the same time I think it does need to go
back to that because d1 was was will had
a quicker ttk so you know so basically
what they're saying is a lot of what
they were talking about especially comes
the time to kill is the lack of
excitement there are no spikes of
intensity and that's what a lot of
people have said that's why it
for many people it's boring to watch on
twitch because primaries to switch
between abilities were really slow to
come back supers weren't that often you
didn't have people sleeping everything
was like just right marries all the time
and after a while that's just like
watching kind of a Call of Duty and
that's not even usually that item 20
exactly no hero moments that's the
problem
so those spikes of you know having a
guardian you know godlike moment you
couldn't do the you know somebody
clutching a one on three because if
they're standing together you're done I
mean there's no way you can kill them
that fact nor do you have you know a
grenade here a dodge here of super to
pop afterwards because if you use it
once and around and you're done so is it
missing out on all that stuff yep so
let's go into some of the changes
they've got ready for one point one
point for let's get it Oh revive and
respawn times were tuned for all game
modes so respawn timers for quickly have
been reduced to two seconds which
honestly that's probably just enough
time to take a breath and get back in
survival and countdown are both reduced
to seven seconds I don't even know what
they were before I don't do as much
competitive so I don't know what they
were at but if it's down to seven
seconds that probably must have felt
like an eternity
so yeah because they died be honest like
at least when I play it revives they
would like few and far between a took so
long a time it was so long yeah players
no longer lose revive tokens on death
interesting so I guess I don't know if
there's a point in those anymore but I
guess we'll see then the other one is
power mo and this is where I have some
giant question marks but won't cover the
numbers first our ammo respawn timers an
iron banner have been reduced 50% so
just iron banner whatever mode it is 50%
faster their power and more respawn
timers for quick play 30 percent
survival 40% countdown 25% more power
ammo which for most people at least in
my view until they change things is more
Rockets right good good point that's
actually a very good point because as we
know as it stands right now in destiny
two meta rockets are the most probably
the most effective power weapons
which leads to the whole argument of why
everything's clumped up in the power
spot we won't get into that again you
know we haven't met but we've done that
we hope knows in the future exactly but
at the end of the day on you know one
would hope that because they're getting
you know this power happen it would
encourage them to use those other you
know there are other power weapons a
little bit more frequently based on the
on the recent one time indeed you know
it's like I don't know for me it's just
like if you have rockets in there more
frequently you don't want it to turn
into mayhem it's right needs to have
some Mayhem's meant to be fun and
chaotic and that's what it's gonna be a
rocket versus super sometimes in there
it's fine but it's just the idea I don't
want normal modes to have rockets all
the time either because they will get to
something else where they're probably
gonna be even more prevalent right
mm-hmm
they said ammo counts have been adjusted
in relation to these timers so in most
cases weapons either retain the same
ammo count or receive a buff swords and
rockets were brought down to stay in
line with the rest of the weapon
offering rockets you still basically
have one so I'm not sure how much you're
gonna bring it down and then you finally
have one all rocket no yeah no I agree I
think that on you know they've gotta
like you know buff up fusions as far as
the ammo count you know make those
things really sexy to take because like
we said you know that rocket that's
gonna be I wonder I'm surprised no an
old school buns you didn't like nerf
rocket just to try to bring everything
else up not that I wanted that but yeah
the only thing they didn't whack them
all with yet so very true but here's the
thing enemy players will now prop drop
their power ammo on death to the brick
the brick is now network to all players
regardless affection secure the power
game excuse me secure the power ammo to
keep it from your foes or steal it off
your enemies ghost but be quick they
don't say the world trip that's huge man
that's huge power ammo and then the
bricks drop and so if somebody doesn't
get to use it somebody else may so
there's gonna be a tendency of more
people
having power a moe mm-hmm-hmm this I'm
cool with this woody buddy's well I'm
excited about this one actually yeah
that's going back all the way to like
vanilla Bethany one yes
yes absolutely correct and I like the
fact that it's not limited to just your
own teammate like anybody can go for
that brick yep yeah I mean if you're
holding it and you die for some reason
it's fair game and Eddie takes skill to
kill someone that already has power a
mold coming at you so it should be
rewarded
I like this I'm very curious to see how
this plays out in the matter yep so yeah
I mean I'm honestly curious like pretty
much is one of those I hope to you know
when we see this up in action I'm again
I just hope they're quicker on the
changes after these big things like if
they do this you know six months for one
point one point four and we're like hey
power I was way too much please don't
wait another three months that's one of
they if they want it to be like you know
night huh scoring you know point nine
it's kind of like a little mini beta or
this the same way they need to be more
responsive if there's pretty resounding
feedback from everyone when this stuff
drops so I hope they're ready to change
quickly and can if it needs to hopeful I
mean I know they do their testing but
not until you get into everybody's hands
as they can actually really change
completely agreement completely agree so
I also say what about competitive so
they wanted to reduce the team shouting
and quick play an iron banner but they
hadn't done quite the same thing and
competitive in their testing so some of
the testing they've done with their you
know things be more powerful but they
still said competitive as Warren team
shutting which makes sense competitive
and trials has a nice new caveat to it
so starting at one point one point four
mm-hmm to remove the tracker which I
guess I assumed to be called the radar
competitive and but we talked about it
last week know are know is basically
competitive you just you just crank it
up a whole new level yeah man I'm
shocked by this I presently pleasantly
shocked that I love that it's a
competitive mode radar
should not be there and we talked about
it before last flashpoint you know one
of my best memories was spooky trials
you know and I forgot what the stage was
a Hellmouth I forgot the name but anyway
um it was just so cool not knowing and
that's what incentivize like they said
incentivize you to flank to go off on
your own that need right now this need
to is that need to clump up to feel safe
right to get the team shot and this is
what I'm talking about and the cool
thing is they're not getting they're not
making it completely hardcore like
spooky trials in a sense that um are
they still gonna be the revived mechanic
shout out to fallout place for I'm
actually mentioned I'm trying to get him
on the show we got to get you on the
show for rollout he's been even Java
some cool tweets and Retin reference to
a crucible bought um yeah man so it's
still gonna head with vibe mechanic but
no radar
trueskill not you know you got a look
around you can choose to stick close you
could choose the Flint
that's what opens it up man so I'm very
excited about I know it's a minor thing
to some but I'm very excited a lot of
people are very very dependent on that
radar and when you take it away like oh
crap I'm like learning to walk again in
this game it really feels that way
yeah and one last point is that um it
brings the fear back you know they're
like you got it you got to be give it is
I'm curious to see how that plays a very
one guy on Twitter basically respond
back to it knees like alright I'm just
gonna put a post-it note on the corner
of my screen like it it's like I'm
training up and getting ready doesn't
put a post-it over the radio I'll put it
on the corner of a screen and dice this
let's go
Oh Corby that's what command if you
think like hey I'm feeling kind of good
go play inferno if you're used to that
radar you're gonna look and it's not
there and all of a sudden oh man but
that's the idea - I mean that allows for
that's where I think power remote could
be useful so if you have a routine up
that one person with the rocket it's
even more effective because you can be
right behind him be like what's up guys
boom and they'll never know so you got
to be communicating talking more so I
think that is a really cool change I'm
glad there's gonna be some type of
Inferno type game-mode so very cool free
totally free and again
making things more distinct it's not
just like you know one version or the
other and actually making those modes
have more of a difference to them which
is kind of what we all want mm-hmm so
next we come to mr. Hamrick and all of
his mentions about what is to come with
one point one point for some of the
balancing and all that fun stuff so he
said basically as I mentioned last time
our goal for the sub data spread
individual players with more hero
moments and that's I think what we all
want that's and one of the biggest
things we want to feel like guardians
again we don't want to feel like we have
to run in a Wolfpack just to survive so
mm-hmm
they said that one increase the
frequency in impact of our most montage
worthy power weapons especially in
crucible and it's supers abilities speed
all that stuff is in there first things
first is like they're very excited for
the update I've seen some tweets from
them go out and they're like you guys
can't believe what is happening right
now I just exploded something done shot
three times they just said it was strum
and something else just like top the
leaderboard and whatever mode they were
running I was like seriously yeah
they're pretty high for this update
I got a given that it you're pretty
excited about what they've done so far
so you know that's good to see
remember it's still Bungie who was like
we had to confirm no but it's like but
they had to confirm auto rifles got
increased by point zero damage and
you're golden
what when you just literally want to
like set your stuff down and walk out of
the room you're like yeah it's like dude
come on now yeah I'm like we all know it
needed more than that because I didn't
change anything it's like well they're
like this multiplies on this ammo it's
like it's not enough we just know it's
not enough so hopefully it's not that
but it seems like a people's heads are
exploding in sidearms and stuff that we
don't even use or when it matches they
got to be doing something all right so
they went over some of these changes
before so we've got some new ones in
bold which will come two big changes on
the dawn blade but they said this is all
about going faster mobility things like
that so they mentioned that all the
glides for and catapult and strafe
they're faster they're more unique the
mobility stat range this is a big one
has been
expanded completely retuned and we can
go faster and the this speed is faster
than ever so there's a big range she a
mobility hopefully will matter huge
especially let's back it up in
conjunction with masterwork armor now we
can configure that stat not everyone's
gonna be just you know over overdoing it
with recovery I'm good
exactly now the role of a master work
you can set up a crucible master work on
a set you know if you want to get a
little bit more crude more on mobility I
love that they needed that mobility need
it to matter prior to this it meant
nothing
I'm sorry strafe speed does it excite me
sorry yeah so yeah I mean I'm looking
forward to it so we've all said the
stats need to mean more this is a step
in the right direction so again they
keep listening pieces at a time baby
step baby step just kind of hopefully
put all the put the puzzle together and
then ship it with taking King 2.0 and
then a we can hope but we'll get to what
it's got a face in the future or so lot
to come so Ark Strider Sentinel and
striker all move faster and at the same
speed as one another while in their
supers Ark Strider as a whole will
actually be having faster animations
increased range so arc stranger is
really gonna be something to compete
with hopefully faster animation so the
Dodgers will be quicker cover ground I'm
scared a faster down there already how
hard to hit when they're going kind of
create me I'm terrible with it I really
am so I need to practice up but man if
they're good with it they're only gonna
get better so that's a little terrifying
the previous shoulder chart changes are
being reverted to allow shoulder charts
to be used more as a movement mode again
which tightens is more happy Jaden's
gonna love that that sounds like skate
and skate in 1.0 that's what the
community wanted mmm-hmm this is all
bold this is new stuff so Don blade has
been improved reduced the cost were
throwing sports plus god I am so
discussed I was so disgusted that Don
blade doesn't even get
and I was what I'm worried that it
wasn't gonna get touched and I super
excited about this that's the my least
used class as a warlock yep so reduce
cost for throwing swords you get an
additional throw increase for duration
extension gain from everlasting fire
moved in air accuracy penalties thank
you that should be across the board but
huge huge especially knock and pull out
my um those wings man
sacred dawn on you reduce the Icarus -
cooldown so you can actually get a
little more shifty in the air you can
increase your grenade and melee energy
heat rises gives you per kill so just
more ability regeneration baby that's
actually a very underrated actually
that's it's a very good perk if you use
that build and it actually gives decent
in my opinion on a grenade and melee
energy especially in PvE when I used to
use it and it's Ryu 'zed to use those
with the wings that giving you more
perky that's a huge deal as a dawn blade
Trevor I put that class through his
paces so I know when they did that I'm
like okay they are now promoting
big-time airplay and I like that Fred
Norman because that's been asking about
yeah I mean they just need to be on
board with giving us the chances to kind
of just have more fun so people are like
why is being the air making me unable to
hit something if I'm gonna jump up in
the air and turn and shoot somebody I
want to be able to show you what I'm
looking at like we're Guardians remember
you told us we are let us be you know
many demigods that we want to be facts
there you go talking alright so next we
come to invisibility which also
terrifying now I think this one affects
console more cousin PC is a little less
of an issue for breaking aim assist
there's basically no aim assist for PC
so this is a bigger thing for console
but bigger audience so understandable
invisibility on dodge no longer breaks
aim assist for projectiles
dodging still breaks both aim assist and
projectile tracking but only during the
dodge increase the duration of
invisibility on dodge by a second so
you're actually invisible long
which is gonna be rough and increases
the direction of the smoke bomb and
visibility by a second as well so pretty
much if you had an issue tracking them
before they're gonna be running around
like little cloaked people all the time
yeah facts and they get I mean they get
the emesis you know thing going on and
then the you know duration of equally by
a second you know smoke one okay you
know I get it I get it to somebody
standing thought they didn't tweet them
I mean I was like it's it's okay I mean
there's one little part in there where
they said unchaste for PvE and I'm kind
of like they have the weakest duh they
have the weakest possibility in the
first place let that dodge give them a
second or two of like okay so but you
know if I'm gonna dodge go invisible and
you know poof out of the way for a
second you know let me actually lose the
PvE immunities to it'd be nice even if
it is for just two seconds keep you
alive a little longer good point good
point I do feel angry with you saying
PvE supers recharge faster for everyone
let's go
supers now recharge a minute and 40
seconds faster a cooldown reduction of
25% let's go
this is what we're talking about feeling
powerful you know those are those
moments in d1 when you know you had your
soup it was it everyone had it at one
time and you got to use it and that's it
it's like that's the way d2 is like just
that one time and you just holding it
and hold it know that it because you
know once you use it that's it you're
not getting it for the entire match so
this is a big deal I definitely enjoy
this yeah well I mean I guess that
answers the question of super recharge
was six minutes and 20 seconds Jesus I
mean that's like if it's 25% that's the
math so it's just like that's so long
yeah that's why we all only got one in a
match like if you got two you must have
been just on a tear exact you had to be
on a god-like spree just to get to it
was just reading stuff that like as a
wall like using like Nazareth sin and um
what's the other helmet has a storm
caller later world yeah like I mean it
just still took forever and these are
things to buff super energy you know
so that yeah that's a huge deal I was
like six minutes is way too long it's
like you don't get it doesn't need to be
a minute but this is hopefully gonna
feel a little better and we should
probably get I wish it was like I like
the 25% time reduction but I still kind
of dislike when everybody gets it at the
same time yeah I agree with you I wish
there was like a caveat
hey it's a minute fifty fifty seconds
faster or forty but also say you know as
you get kills or if you get precision
kills maybe whatever something so people
would get them at different times yes
would be a little more staggered nailed
the feel you'd be like a runner you
didn't know you and it would just be one
of those things to be like hey you never
know who's gonna quite have one stuff
like that so completely agree that's a
great point actually yeah a little more
staggering but hopefully you know if
people get it quicker they'll probably
spread it out a bit more and maybe get
two so we'll just see mm-hm so mods that
reduced cool get rid grenade melee and
class ability cooldowns have been buffed
to allow up to two times faster
cooldowns this is not replacing mods 2.0
which is that's gonna be big later this
is basically just currently mods are
going to give it our basically gonna get
up to two times faster so I guess the
stacking is gonna get more noticeable if
you put those together so that's all
that's big I mean twice as fast on
cooldown reduction that's the more the
merrier on some of that stuff if you're
gonna stack and not get any other perks
you means we'll get the bigger bigger
benefit out of it exactly we're talking
about abilities man that and you know
people want to use it I just don't want
to use it once and take so long for it
to come back so now the bots have some
long you know effectiveness we'll we'll
see now this is this is good yeah I mean
and sticky grenades don't kill it's like
I know a lot of people hate it's
thinking your needs before but now so
many of those things feel like all the
time that you're taking to throw a
grenade or all the time that you're
taking the melee somebody shooting and I
always lose those battles so what I use
my abilities I shouldn't feel like I'm
making the wrong decision absolutely and
at least they have the balance like you
said right right where the sticky
grenade is not doing the one shot
because then it becomes ability spam and
that's what we don't want right we don't
want ability spam but we do want the
little bit more frequency and you're
still gonna have to finish off with
primary gum
for the most part with these grenades
none of these none of these really
aren't doing like a lot of one-shotting
you know with these uh grenades no yeah
like there's a whole like deep dive we
could do and it's like do I think
shoulder charge should be able to kill
you no one here probably because
otherwise you're gonna like lose that
thing seems so weak but I mean that's
rebuffing ability isn't it
discussion later by discussion but I
mean I like just I like the fact that
they're gonna be cut you can get them
even quicker and especially if you
choose to mod fourth and you're gonna
get the benefit so they're they're
getting there next to counter to the
weapons so this is where lots of changes
are happening for everything let's go
how are you uh jumping at your seat yet
yeah how much do I have me excited bit
I'm ready let's go alright so starting
with and this is just gonna go down the
row in no order just whatever they have
on the page we've got pulse rifles now
almost all of these I'll say this now
increased PvE damage for all of said
weapon type almost everything in here
has that no PD damage across the board
for just about everything so I guess
they're helping us kill stuff quicker
yes just in general like less bullets
Bungie I'm kind of good I don't know if
that PvE is like 1% or 15% I mean how
much of a buff do you think this is
substantial um the reason being I mean I
just don't like peak holsters in PvE I
just don't they just feel weak to me and
one of my favorites was the UM the
trials looking gun um and um it's you
know it's cool it's just like it just
doesn't effectively kill like the other
weapons so sonic is also they had to do
something with it and um it's gonna be
curious to see how the meta ships cuz
I'm noticing they sing rate of fire base
damage for adaptive high-impact in rapid
fire pulses so um yeah we're gonna see
we're gonna see how this goes across the
board there's still like they saying
that they're keeping the percentage
precision damage close to where it's now
putting most of the buff into the body
shots so uh yeah it's gonna be
interesting out this plays out hopefully
it's not one of those you
zero 0.1% kind of deals and um but I get
I get the feeling it's not this is just
my guesstimate I think they're going
they're gonna go hard with this and I
think four pulse rifles it's probably
one of the biggest busts because I think
between everything they're probably the
least used so it's probably fair that
they put this at the top of the list
because I think they're pretty
underutilized across the board time
pulses have seen better days I mean I
miss the days of like red death and all
that stuff so but it is nice like
increase rate of fire for some increased
base damage increased precision
multiplier for the lightweight ones
decreasing like they're making some
noticeable changes damage across the
board I mean these are going to feel
different and hopefully definitely in
line with that they should be the whole
big time so scout rifles PvE damage for
all Scouts increase base damage for high
impacts yes please high impacts are
useless in my opinion that archetype and
it's just not effective I have an
amazing new monarchy one um off get the
name of it ah she got it - yeah yeah
shout out to my man dizzy he put me on
to it and I think it has the stowaway
perk that reloads its oh man it's so
good but I'm like this really doesn't
hit for the slow week we you know
reloading in the rain you know it
doesn't hit hard like a you know name
was midnight that the high impact has to
be they have to separate it so I'm so
glad they specifically addressed it
because there's a lot of high impact
Scouts that if you look if you compare
them stat wise to the regular stuff it's
not that big of an impact
Jarnell it's really not and as is the
one thing I wish they would get into
even just a little bit more like each
make a low impact scout be something
that's got a little more solid range
mm-hmm noticeably more bullet to the
clips say something more like 25 but and
you know pepper more shots out there
versus somebody who's like you want to
hit that one main shot it's gonna hit
hard like yep have a bigger range in
because you have a scout rifle we have
these classes make bit bigger ranges in
these classes otherwise you really only
have like six weapon types if you want
to have like eight
Dean give us a bigger range within those
eh eh and again I'm not a creator I'm
sure balancing a vehicle if you do that
this one turns into an auto rifle or
this man I'm like so I was like I know
it's a tough line to walk but if you
want to give us like here's your three
types right we know these are the types
they need to feel different as opposed
to just like you know light on one and
be done yeah absolutely it's got it's
got to hit hard to me just gotta hit
hard at distance that that to me is what
the high-impact Scout should be doing
you know a bolt-action sniper like
almost that's how the thought process
was for me at least in d1 you know I
have a key test and all that other stuff
and you know all you know you wonder you
sacrifice the accuracy and the recoil
but if you land the shot it should hurt
like that split second longer make sure
that recoil comes back and you get those
good shots but when you do land them
they hit pretty hard for pulsus shades
minor wins mercy let's go I called up
and casitas now I know what you're
talking about increased PvE damage for
all hand cannons oh hey I mean hand
cannons are pretty good higher precision
hand cannons no precision that means
you're slower harder hit equals I'm
guessing actually don't know which ones
those oh yeah I forgot I think those was
they said precision so I think those the
ones they think isn't that adaptive
class there's a couple of good ones man
I forgot to mean I wonder if I'm better
Devils falls into that precision you
continue that's a good question
increased hipfire accuracy on consoles
increase ATS accuracy on consoles so
definitely some some help to the hand
cannon leveling consoles because
honestly I'm PC they're great yeah man
they're not so much awesome so yeah they
could use some help which is hey I'm
fine with that sidearms increased PvE
damage for sidearms these could probably
use a major boost in PvE again
if you're up fairly close that's only
wear side arms are effective and you're
gonna switch if I'm doing the raid and
one of those guys comes up in front of
me and this is my alternative you better
start hitting a little harder other way
I'm gonna be just shooting peanuts at
this guy he's like a fax shoutout to the
Rat King that's not doing anything
yeah increase adsf curacy increased
inventory size so more reserve animo
increase minimum range which is good and
added an 80s movement bonus so if you're
holding the pistol you're probably a
little more mobile than say you're
holding and you know a rifle so that is
actually fairly logical so I like that
smg's increased PvE damage for all and
some G's again just across the board PvE
getting that boost you set the optics to
1.3 x just apparently across the board
so that's dope and also increased
reserve ammo as well which makes sense
smg's burned through ammo sidearms you
can probably do it as well I mean auto
rifles seem like you have what six seven
hundred clip like bullets on a decent
sized Uriel's gift you have a lot yes
item two the SMG seemed to burn through
him a little quicker so I like to see
that coming
agreed linear fusion rifles how often
have you ever used one of these things
by the way it's no burn in my life
seriously and that has the the idea of
like raids with the tailored weapons
that you had to use and they threw this
one in there to probably be like at some
point we're gonna make you guys do it
it's good we swear it's good like it's a
large up sniper rifle yeah you have to
lead you have to be ready when that shot
goes off and unless it's just a static
boss like callous there's not a lot of
uses so if you buff this thing you
better hit harder than a sniper rifle in
my opinion like a linear fusion rifle to
me honestly but I'd probably be okay
with like what what if it was like a one
shot in PvP money
yeah they got to make it like mom needs
to be a guy what was the one that used
to get for prisoner elders oh it was a
um it was an exotic you got it from
president elders it was a fallen style
weapon it was like you know what I'm
talking money per what is the deposit
eluded me right there I was like it's
been a while since I'm uh
they gotta make them play like that they
gotta make them hit they gotta make him
hit a little harder they had on you know
I don't want to get too cheesy but you
almost gotta say like one shot I don't
know I mean I was like I mean it could
because I mean you get people who are
good with a linear like people across
the way cuz it's like a mini sniper you
pop out at the wrong time boom boom is
vaporized now increased precision
multiplier that's good for PvE so
actually put some more damage into
bosses which is nice mmm-hmm increased
aim assist or reduce flinch multiplier
so getting a little more feel of sniper
help which is good ah
so we'll see if those actually come
abuse but those need a huge buff I think
to be even viable absolutely exam
shotguns increased PvE damage for all
shotguns which is a good thing I mean
shotguns in PvE are it's a risk versus
reward I'm gonna reward to be a little
bigger so I agree I don't like that some
more ammo increased force arose
precision shotguns which is you know
that's a big deal yeah that's a big deal
because uh that class actually reminds
me of the chaperone if the slugs one hit
and that's a big deal because you want
to reward that skill what skill type
weapon so hitting them up with a little
more aim assist to make that viable
those can be deadly if they if it's done
right they can own me the NFRC I mean
the damage on PvE that's a big deal
tonight I'll use the UM of a great shot
oh my god actually I got some
controversial oh you got everybody's
like going all perfect paradox when it
came out yeah and don't get me wrong
perfect paradox is amazing the whole
quest line is a Ponte bah blah but I did
with the last time I did a rage the eat
is a world I got the Zeeman the zenith
of your kind shotgun to drop that thing
right there is beast and it has all it
has the store way which it reloads
automatically it's got to build similar
perks and I think one little different
perk but I masterwork
bro that thing is a beast I'm just
imagining now with these changes you
know how I was gonna play that and
paradox I think it's gonna be pretty
pretty serious yeah I was like I could I
mean I honestly hadn't toyed with
shotguns that much in a while but I was
thinking for masterworks if they were
just a bit stronger and you could bump
out you know six or seven with
masterworks you might have some more
orbs dropping because rockets I think
need their master work fixed if I'm
gonna blow my rocket am on a nice I want
like six orbs to drop I mean I mean let
me tell you this right now advances and
this is current d2 meta I either have
the paradox or my zenith of your kind
and remember it's full auto that's the
other thing it's full or you will melt
yellow bars nice like you it's an
aggressive stuff I had to change my
whole style like I'm going up in front
of the bosses and you know by my momma
and this thing is just running through
it it's beast man oh man I think the
right indicator some great perks on it
like love zenith of your con that's my
shotty of the year so I'm ready to try
it out yeah I'm telling you all your
perfect products don't come at me man
zine it of your kind
that is the shotty to have snipers love
I actually saw the little clip they put
up and I think it will be here totally
they got a clip of snipers giving a
little more action so I don't know if it
was just like somebody who's using it
was pretty solid whoever their tester
was that was already using it I don't
know if they like hatecraft do you want
to come shoot for us I mean whoever it
was is pretty good because I don't think
I'd be making those shots but it looked
viable so look yeah we'll see precision
let's see honestly it's like you see him
doing that have him go like hand cannon
if the heavy animals that and that
snipers the in-between I still like the
d1 feel about that other slot back
doesn't haven't having a sniper like be
down a lane mmm you turn into your
rocket coming at you it's like it can go
both ways that way yeah absolutely
you're right I mean as much as act
terrible with him I mean I do miss
seeing them I miss two people who were
skilled with them so this is good stuff
was it
and though it's not Parthenon that's the
thing over in Europe I love that map I'm
not the best sniper but I can tell you
if I have certain longer a map that's
truly built for it I would piss some
people off sometimes I know people get
out tonight me I'm not gonna claim to be
the best I have some moments where it
was like you learned like when they walk
out they're gonna be in line with this
wall and it's just and back and forth
and just like pop pop pop pop and I'm
like crap I gotta reload and I got all
four is like but it feels awesome
yeah we don't get like otherwise or now
we just have to wait for the heavy ammo
one person gets it and I don't get to
have those skill moments as often so the
point is it increased precision
multiplier increased aim assist
increased inventory sighs so just boost
you get a boost you get a bit especially
to deal with the the flinch as it
currently is I'm not gonna talk about
later but it was a huge deal mm-hmm I'm
like that's it really is so trash we
really think this is gonna do I have no
faith again I'm willing to give it a
shot but I don't see these things
competing I don't know like blast radius
needs to be either massive or quicker or
more accurate but it's just like it
it's just limping along being a weapon
type right now it's at this point I
think they need to cut their losses real
talk advances and make it an energy
weapon I mean why not like no one's
picking that no one's gonna sit there
you know what I'm not gonna use sins in
the past I'm not gonna use you know ward
cliff did it I can't think of any
scenario I gotta tell argument one of
the lords Oh
shout out to my man demon cuz he's like
he's one of those guys that like any
weapon can be effective in a certain
situation yeah it's an extent but which
are you really gonna be choosing a
grenade launcher in nine times out of
ten out of anything else and the only
thing a situation I think we came up
with was like PvE you know and you stun
a captain
you know and you know it kind of it's
like it has like a stun mechanic yeah
that's about it yeah I mean we'll see
blast radius
what about damage launches that's Elia
I'm sorry yeah that's definitely in the
last column I find it weird they say
assault rifles I guess that's just auto
rifles but yeah I think they were called
assault rifles but Negus intention
increased range and aim assist stats for
precision autos Uriel's gift based
damage has not changed yeah so aim
assist precision new firing I guess
we'll just see I mean Uriel's is pretty
crazy we know that type is it's up there
so bringing it just pulling it back a
hair and that's probably all right a lot
of things needed boosts which is good if
you got to bring back the one that's a
little out of line yeah that one yeah
the precision autos that they dominate
right now so I can see this nerf for a
little bit I can understand yeah I'm not
like more things coming up to it because
that one's more of a seed that I think
people enjoy but if I guess maybe some
boosts across the board change things up
but the only thing they didn't mention
though was nowhere in that list was any
boost so I guess auto rifles I'm pretty
much where they're at that's a good
point
that's a good point especially the other
auto rifle archetypes yeah that's a good
point it makes me wonder like if they're
bringing everything up but it's only up
to auto rifles mm-hm think about a
normal auto rifle in PvE mmm but I mean
I guess I don't know PvE it's like I
don't want to walk around like two godly
so there's a point of overdoing it but
yeah I guess in PvP and we'll see I was
like I'd like like I can get like a
little more and then bring everything up
to it now oh god sure not as soon as you
say that's what you say I also talked
about a few perks high impact reserves
that's gonna be increased PV damage kill
clip increase PvE damage rampage
increase PvE damage increase duration
which is nice
dragon fly increased damage increase
radius stronger visual effects yeah
grave-robber reloads
half as opposed to a third of the
magazine time to payload splits damage
55 explosive 45 direct instead of
previous split which was more direct
damage okay I don't even know what
that's on honestly but which one was
which was timed payload I don't know if
that's a grenade launcher I'm not that
sound grenade launcher is that something
I don't never see I don't know it's
probably on grenade explosive rounds
decrease PvE rounds explosive round
damage now this one makes me wonder what
about those better Devils and nameless
ponies you know that you know what that
nerf is about that dad nerf is for those
two goods I know it is but unfortunately
like those are the ones that make you
feel like you can actually damage some
stuff like if I put a hand cannon
straight into the middle of a goblin
walking around right into his crit spot
in his chest yeah I do want to blow him
in half like I should do that and I
don't only use better Devils so if I go
walk around with another hand cannon I
got a two shot you in the chest again
like it this is this is borderline
whack-a-mole them seeing that those guns
are the most used because of that
particular perk so yeah this is back of
all
Aquila you know this has been
compensated for with an increase in PvE
damage for the base weapons your weapons
with explosive rounds will not do less
damage after one point four so they do
acknowledge the worry which is but still
it's like explosive rounds if if that
part is that good see why other perks
alright there you go max just like last
time we have a few additional notes to
wrap up things but that's most so
they've got mobs rework so first let's
talk about changes to potency of ability
cooldown mods in our last update we
mentioned that we were going to wait and
buff ability cooldowns so basically
they're just going to not delay all of
that so as they said they're gonna give
the ability cooldowns in their huge mods
update later so we know it's coming cool
cool
invisibility as mentioned above you know
currently like things are a little bit
there that kind of bringing the
invisibility in line basically they just
said yeah we know you guys are having
fun you're kind of awesome but if you're
just hunters we got to pull you back a
little bit you're crushing it too much
the hunt is always gonna feel away
though I have to admit as a warlike I do
doubt cat about my friend shadow citizen
he always could plays like oh it does
kind of feel but I understand again with
this it makes sense you don't want it to
get out of control but he's like he that
is conspiracy theory
she's always yeah so so coming in one
point one point four so PvP only Pat
changes so the initial initiate Dodger
throw smoke so dodging temporarily kills
aim assist as we said smoke immediately
smoke just immediately jumps to non
Tyler's here with that bullet initiated
visibility Oh smoke immediately just
immediately jumps to initiate yeah yep
so just pretty much the things they said
before so but most of its PvP for now
overall perks and stuff that's just
coming later right finally they did
mention snipers in the last update they
said you know that bug crept in so they
couldn't fix the sniper flinch they
found the bug
unfortunately they found the bug but
it's gonna be one point two so we gotta
wait for me so sweet sniper action is on
the way I'm not sure why it's two months
and not like two weeks yeah I don't know
with that I was like if you found it why
don't you whack that mole as well
yeah I mean I'm gonna try to be nice you
know this guy there's got to be a reason
you know they found it but yeah you
would like that to be in line with the
UM you know there's one point one point
four because you know with the amiable
you know you want snipers to be viable
and if the flinch is still a problem you
know they're gonna get you know
outdueled by primaries you know I know
they brought the
my sister so that's good you know and in
damnit will see we sit we see but I am a
little mini disheartened by that yeah
for the sniper attacks and I'm not even
psycho guy yeah I'm usually not I try to
be on certain Maps I knew there were
ones that I was like no like I'm not
going to last night fine
you know anomaly or anything like that I
was like I'm not that good so there are
certain maps that are built for it I had
some chances but no the ones who
definitely liked it it's like get it in
there quicker otherwise it's just not
soon enough said this is not the end you
know they're excited they want to get it
in our hands okay get it in our hands
and then finally they have a note below
so the video that they posted up and I
said on that note below you'll find a
video pulled from a 1-point 2.0 play
test that has all the one point one
point for sniper changes and the new
sniper flinch fixes and it works so they
have it there they had it in a plate but
also their play testing one point two
right point one point four isn't out but
that also probably means one point one
point four has been done mm-hmm like
what is their development cycle to push
it out to production is it does it have
to be done a month before we even see it
as opposed to people that are like for
you know other games I'll say for some
time it's like hey this patch is done
we've been testing it for a few days
it's in the wild like the next week like
that timing still seems so yeah it's
almost like an over thoroughness you
know and it's like it's like we talked
about you know flashpoint 6 it's okay to
make a tweak see how it plays get it out
this you know it plays and then you know
come back as opposed to trying to get
this perfection all the time and it's
like let's get back to the fun put it
out there see how the community receives
it and then readjust you know I'm saying
if we be you know I feel like they're in
the lab really long like I just get a I
know they're so data-driven I know it's
like how they work but they've got to
find a balance I understand if you throw
stuff out too quick it could break but
you gotta be you gotta be quicker to
adapt these six months three months
they're too long so long you have to be
concise you just nailed it for tonight
is the perfect example they're getting
molds every time I look every week it's
like oh they got this
21:20 own and it's dissonant it's again
two different games
the devs I'm not trying to be
disrespectful no but we have to be clear
as to if we want to save this thing
these when people get so excited about
this update did you see the community
tweet people excited right so that's
showing you if there's this excitement
level is there you've gotta be more
frequent or got a huge staff it's just
to the point of if people want these
changes you want to I mean they'll play
it for this but they're like if the next
update six months from now played it for
a few weeks and me like I'll just
probably feedback you know maybe haven't
the rotation as opposed to every week
something news in there am i checking
this thing I don't like the incentive
for every week right now unless it's a
major content drop for ninety five
percent of us is probably not there but
if it's like hey I'm playing this all
next week a comes back yeah I'll
probably play out a couple once or twice
this week because there's something new
in there hey there's this and it's like
the continuous they need to I was like I
mean in the world of Daleville it's like
get off of like the waterfall the big
plane and go as though they come quicker
man gotta go quick yeah you got two men
you know you have to change resources
whatever you got to do to make that
happen
shout out so whoever's sniping in this
video though I don't wanna play against
you playing those are some solid shots
they go on to talk about the Destiny
companion app you guys can read that in
the update basically they're just
working on making it you know more
effective shaders around masterworks
perks all that stuff you can just kind
of use it for what you need to find they
also cover some patches some patch notes
little bugs you know they said the EDC
emblem only 30 shows 38 ghosts there's
41 they talked about Wi-Fi for
connections and things like that and
it's like if you got Wi-Fi yeah you
probably know it's not perfect me I just
paint it but I put a hard line in my
house I'm on I'm on a hard line all the
time so pulled my cord out and I wasn't
if you were talking about it will Rhea
and then share that too esoteric by the
way in a week you got it it's been a
long time coming for that guy like one
did solo night falls he does he's
honestly probably more skillful than I
am I'll give it to him hats off he could
probably run or train around me but yeah
shout out to that guy dude he's awesome
he does so many solo things he finally
got it so just wanted to give a huge
shout out to him because that's what
long overdue and well deserved he so
loves everything which is awesome - easy
as well so it's super talented yep so
we've got so here's the movie week
winners we've also got the nightfall top
scorers mm-hmm as well now there's a
caveat to this and that's why I want to
see so you've got since Tuesday would
quite a few players asking with the
nightfall top scorers will be
highlighting the top five times you each
week as a note we're aware of an issue
where lost sectors are currently
contributing points to nightfall
scorecard or aiming to resolve this so I
update 1.2 and to resolve you may find
the top scores to be huge which
unfortunately kind of means and you
gotta cheese it which I don't know what
it takes to like you know whatever the
night fell is gonna be for the week just
block off the lock sectors like if you
load into a nightfall in that I mean you
only have a certain you have a timer on
it so you're gonna do it anyway you have
to finish it just like put up the
invisible walls I've seen him before
put them on just don't let him walk in
there so right I don't know whatever I
don't know what that takes but I feel
like that could be a switch so hmm they
said the law structure sector strategy
may live until May but they're actively
collecting data score parts for the in
valyrian sir still 20 40 60 80 K but
expect these to adjust it in the future
high scores achieved through creative
use of law sectors will not be factored
in when settling these new score parts
so at least they're taking that when
they're thinking about what's to come I
mean if you got 226 you still have two
people run through
a bunch of stuff the other ones like I
mean you have a pretty orchestrated
thing going on it's just not as intended
something when I see you know esoteric
get 114 dado got like 120 like four or
nine or enemies like we could have been
a little higher and it's and there was
some randomness to the night falls or as
well extreme probabilities is literally
all about the infinite forest
what's your run it from there real quick
I want to shout out a Kris covertly in a
chat um he's talking about he was
running a Wi-Fi connection I wanted to
actually reiterate they actually talked
about that you just grow up a little bit
the source of an inference of Wi-Fi
connections and they actually stressed
they kind of telling people to kind of
go away from y5 and play destiny I was
like interesting that they actually had
a whole paragraph you see that paragraph
was like source of interference for uh
why fact that if you scroll up a little
bit yeah and um I was like this is
interesting you know saying so yeah
shout to Crisco be he's telling me
talking I use Wi-Fi and I was like yeah
I don't actually just made a statement
right now so it's almost like they're
not guaranteeing you having the greatest
experience because of me so I thought
that was interesting that they had to
make a note of this it's just one of
those I mean a lot of people just expect
Wi-Fi to be one of those things that I
mean you think about your phone and the
stuff you do on there and Wi-Fi but if
you're gonna play something that's like
high feedback all the time unless you're
running with an amazing router like
awesome paying great connection Wi-Fi
still not gonna be as good you still
have that time of you know data transfer
between it's quick but it's still not as
quick so it's I mean it's fine to shout
it out occasionally it's just like for
the non technically inclined people who
are like hey just want my shooter to
work unfortunately Bungie with their non
dedicated servers and things like that
all you can do now on PC I don't think
I've ever had that issue it's through
battlenet and my assumption is like I
don't know if PC really has that issue
actually so but on console for sure I
haven't done much PvP on there in ages I
got a feeling it still still feel
somewhat like destiny so I understand
yeah I understood but yeah don't try and
um play gaming in one room and then try
and have your router in the room that's
behind the Superman
probably gonna work I can't have a
microwave going on as well don't have
your router right behind your fridge
that's a line for your wall your flyer
fireplace and then your bedroom that's
like you got six things in the way for a
straight shot
probably not boo so that's this week at
Bungie what do you think this is this is
what you were waiting for stand now I
gotta get your overall feels I gotta be
honest I was this was above expectation
for the most part I would say um you
know I would say like earth-shattering
what I think you know if they this what
they need if they can give me a series
of one point one point fours
yeah you know with regular intervals I'm
gonna be excited I'm gonna see like this
type of stuff in bunches for me is like
I love to go back into the game
retouch those those things that have
gotten buffed or changed and see
effectiveness and see how a new meta
develops so this type of stuff this type
of minutiae excites me literally now I
don't even think is I should actually
discredit it by saying man I think
there's a lot of good changes the super
is the cool downs you know that the
sandbox changes
I was surprised we got a lot of PvE
increases yeah that's actually nice yeah
so that that wasn't you know that was
out of left field you know we got a lot
of good stuff in here so again is it
going to bring everyone back
probably not however this is how you
start on the road to recovery
you know I mean and again it's like you
said frequency frequency frequency they
got to keep this up they got to keep
this up you know so we'll see so I would
say how would I would say this is a
strong update can't disrespect it couple
of minor weird things here and there
just a nitpick or for the most part I'm
I'm okay what do you feel about it I
mean in general as well so I guess I'm
bigger in PvE than PvP I like the boost
to PvE now again I wonder how much that
is especially
they're bringing explosive rounds down
they're not doing anything the auto
rifles like I feel of time to kill in
PVE with auto rifles and certain thing
sorry in certain things with auto rifles
I'm like not sure that PvE boost is
really gonna be huge I mean it is some
and for stuff like pulse rifles it did
desperately need it because I don't know
of anybody who are delay uses them
they're not viable they're not an
especially an afterthought I would just
put them away
mm-hmm I mean but in general I like a
lot of what they're doing I mean they're
trying to make things more viable in
lots of places
hashtag r.i.p grenade launchers you know
put them in their gravestone now start
making you know you may as well just set
them down put them away either bring
back either put him in that energy slot
I want to see a machine you know machine
guns come back mm-my thunderlord oh so
many PvE kills with that thing so many
but I mean like what they're doing I
mean they're working on it's really
specifically like you know base damage
for high impact Scouts that's something
that like we know it's like if I'm gonna
use that in PvE I want that thing to hit
hard I want that thing to be a three
shot because it's harder to do
I mean accuracy and hand cannons
sidearms you know ATS move it's just the
little things that makes them feel more
like the archetype you'd want to picture
in your head all these positive changes
so as you said is it what's gonna be you
know the one that's like hey everybody
come back to destiny no but are these
all the things that are working on
setting it up yes and I think these
sound at least until we get it in our
hands what are pretty much all good
changes mm-hmm so I wanted to bring
something up wasn't me that we ended the
blob and uh we added this in the title
and you made a cool little thumbnail
someone else bits that happen this week
are happening yes I wanted to talk about
that because um you know as we know you
know shout out to you last flashpoint
man you you got you got the mind going
and we had a great you know Ted Judah
you know the taken king moment right
yeah when it should have and how it
should happen what they should do
you gotta and um you know I'm think I'm
sitting yeah I'm alright I guess some
new players in the game you know and we
know that already with the fortnight was
out there master hunter and all that
stuff but guess who returned from the
shadows yeah so Division two does exist
so as you guys can see on screen massive
announced and it was literally on their
blog but they do and I honestly I got a
shout out massive and the team over who
work on the division the community
people who they do a weekly like almost
a weekly thing if not weekly it's pretty
frequent but it's the way Bungie does
their major releases for like you know
the expansion they'll do a couple
streams they do streams just to talk
about updates taking questions and like
more community true interaction and
discussion I mean yes for Bungie they
get to where you know they like to have
it all organized perfectly in word edge'
yeah yeah there's available freely
massive I agree yeah so it's just a
little more open and you know rolling
with some possible you know flubs in
chat because it happens often you do it
enough you're not gonna say it perfect
but they say those they do it frequently
and gotta give them props for that but
it announced they're like hey just live
on one of their discussions they're like
we are working on division two so it is
now there's no dates of wind there's no
information other than that they said we
won't see anything but it will be at e3
so if you're going to e3 look forward to
that good point
this changes things about just we got
talk you know we got to go because I was
going to jump in alright here's um as
you know shout to look how about -
because he's a division guy and we used
to go ahead the visiting this to me is
not only very intelligent but it up by
our division Ubisoft being no destiny to
struggling right now right um shades of
d1 if we go back to history
um d1 you know was in a struggle period
the
came out and it stole that base it stole
that but it had a good run in the
beginning right I think it became came
out I forgot what was the DLC did it
come out before taking Kingdom from
checking my timeline right d1 was a year
after so if it was September of 2013
that right no September 2014 because ps4
was 2013 okay so 2014 15 16 and then
this was 17 yeah that'd be right three
full years so 14 division I want to say
came out it wasn't March of 2015 it had
to be 2016 yeah it was definitely a
March or and April kind of I would say
like a March kind of a month is when it
released but I was gonna get the
timeline as far as what was the last
prior destiny failure slash deals
because destiny wasn't a law but a
Content law when they came out yeah so
give me a second on my phone i always go
real quick yeah I need the timeline cuz
we got it we got to take this thing back
man because this is always says it
almost feels March of March of 2016 suit
I've had taken King in the fall of 2015
big September launch you had all of that
but there was no season pass like that's
where you're talking about the law and
this comes March like is this gonna be
the Destiny killer right cuz so
basically let's go back in time right
yep taking King was out for some time
and then everybody finally did
everything right yeah they finally
blazed off everything and there was
nothing at that time in the horizon I
think they just did like a mine a little
spring update I think they added the
malach thing maybe at that time after
the fact maybe April but it still wasn't
enough it wasn't like a full-fledged
boom DLC until late rise of iron right
yeah now the full year yeah they had
that yes not quite daunting but yeah
there was the malach like kind of a
strike which is basically a reskin in
Reverse right and there wasn't a ton to
it so yeah absolutely
so basically like I said st I think it
was in a good place as far as the
gameplay the mechanics but the material
was a drought of content
we know what the talent wants here comes
the vision bone March highest-selling
new IP you know deeper deep you know mid
max game you know customization stuff
like that people come to this thing in
droves
everybody's like destiny is in trouble
right we didn't get a lot of updates at
that time it wasn't that much clarity
you know I'm saying now over time as you
got deeper with division you start to
see a little bit of the flaws you
started to see a little bit you know the
endgame wasn't as deep it wasn't there
weren't no promise raids I remember
these fictional stories about this raid
and Rikers Island yours
none of that be true I forgot what they
would call like excursions I encourage
it you know I'm saying and um basically
it was one of those things where it was
like okay it just kind of made a few
mistakes you start the stumble and then
eventually it actually came back
Rasen Ryan came back and everybody was
kind of full force and then they died
believe the last thing with the vision
was to cheating the engine issues you
know they didn't have a dedicated PvP
and then they kind of really died off
the player base really that off from the
vision and then kind of destiny came
back right however now let's
fast-forward destinies in a worse place
it's not even now that there's not even
a lot of content the game people are not
happy with the core gameplay of the game
I think this is genius move on division
honestly the key is gonna be when does
it release and if it's do you even think
it would be ready for fall of this year
probably not but you never know if it's
this year wall-e bonta's whoa I don't
know I'm scared I mean it came out in
March of 16 if you go Bungie cycle
through years you go division cycle give
it a full three years you drop it in
March main reasons Call of Duty for
black or B color due to blacks ops for
got announced we all know there's a Call
of Duty that's not a big surprise but
still sells like gangbusters we know
it's gonna sell now it is even gonna
have competition because
rock stars walk into the table with red
nevia - so you've got that you've
potentially got something in destiny in
there and that's where we're gonna talk
here in a second mm-hmm
you even had Nintendo we're gonna have
to bring them up a little bit but yeah
they're direct yesterday they said smash
their last little bit Smash Brothers got
their little glimpse 2018
sometime in this year and you gotta
imagine that's gonna be a October
November December main holiday selling
title because that's one so you've
already got a pretty stacked deck there
with just those three chests was three
huge and I have to double down on the
point you made um in reference to call
it duty because even though it's under
the same family of Activision with
destiny destiny has always had those two
months to breathe right
September is when their DLC always comes
out you know then they have October and
then November will come and that's Call
of Duty but for the most part they
didn't step on each other right too much
and there was a little space
now with the Red Dead effect and Call of
Duty moves up to October you know that's
a big deal
because even if destiny has a Fant let's
say it sticks to form and it had it
comes out in September
probably like first week or two December
so you have one month not good
the Activision I mean Call of Duty can
eat at that cold do is we cannot
understate that no holders you yeah it's
still a powerhouse I mean is it got the
wind in its sails that it's used to no I
mean it is a point of saturation that
people like there's other things
there's your pub jeez there's your
fortnight's that is still are crushing
it by the way well Call of Duty still is
one of the biggest games of the year
it just is I mean whether it's all the
teenagers buy it whatever there's
certain markets that still flock to that
release every year and that's their
that's their thing for a couple months
fact and in the whole community that
they engage with that so let's just say
that we know that happen October right
if destiny sticks of September coal
duties October red Dead's October
you know right right that's two weeks
after college early that's insane that
means October let's be real it's gonna
be hard to touch destiny with those two
powerhouses running loose in the street
right you know they're coming if you
know hey I know I'm gonna buy call of
duty cool red dead holy crap it's the
first one since Rockstar in five years
probably cuz literally cuz Grand Theft
Auto 5 was ps3 360 and then like came
over so it's been a solid five years
it's time and I came sells like nothing
else I mean that's gonna top the NPD's
because it's not colony it's the one
thing that kicks them off of it so max
that's without a question there's also
gonna be a battlefield say yes another
one so I mean that's EA bringing those
to the table do they do it a week in
between if you do it after Red Dead are
you screwed do you put it in November so
you give it a couple weeks we're gonna
do that it's good really full so right
my assumption is division has to wait
till at least either winter which is
technical but whatever 2019 early
somewhere in there that's my feel you're
probably right for fit cuz I don't
really I don't think for them to try and
compete on against all of that I don't
just don't think it's smart and I also
don't think they need to if they've done
what they have been able to do this far
along yeah
Anubis off wants to support it the
Ubisoft sorry yeah if they want to
support it I think they're at this point
hey we want you guys to do it right I
think they probably have a window where
like a you've been milking this thing
along but I think they there's I think
they're smart enough not to put it in a
place to have it fail yeah I mean I
would agree with you conventional wisdom
would say they will not come out this
year that they will show this year we'll
get preview trailer they'll have a big
they already said they're gonna be at e3
I'll be at e3 you have a big presence
there I'm hopefully get my hands on it
you know give you those exclusive those
IOP exclusives once we get the info but
um yeah man I tend to agree I'm just
nervous like this let's just say it at a
crazy world
I don't know it's not enough of me to go
around
mm-hmm enough for me to try and play all
this stuff cuz I never read one I'll be
honest I'm what I like I've always heard
cool thing okay so just jump into to you
know hopefully PC launches there which I
think pcs getting a little more popular
so hopefully these are more concurrent
releases is gonna look good it's gonna
be kind of its own thing I'm sure it's a
story depth game kind of like Grand
Theft Auto was but you know as
successful as GTA online has been that's
probably given them more income than the
actual sales of the base game so online
it made so much money from that they're
gonna have a version of that for reddit
Redemption mm-hmm
where do you find time for another
online game with all of the stuff coming
and then two of them whatever destiny to
whenever it falls if it's September you
might get a month and then you're about
to run out of time for other stuff hacks
or do you go face straight off with
division with destiny to - um yeah then
you got me thinking about these two
other factors here you know call duty
move their date in fear let's mean let's
call it what it is they move because the
red day no absolutely the history of
call duty has always sold that November
up yep now this one year out of nowhere
they know that Rockstar they understand
what rockstars doing over there and put
on yeah so my thing is okay what if they
follow your advice from last flashpoint
right which is don't put it out
September actually delay it wait till
it's done now I'm worried about okay if
you do that do you think they I don't
think they would pull out DLC in
December right if they if they waited
they wait they would go kind of like a
spring kind of thing I would think um
and then you risk that dropping in
conjunction with division which we
assume drops early 2019 yeah that's my
feel but yeah that's I mean then you
face another one like this one had it I
mean you watch the numbers on twitch
like when division came out you
literally watched you know if you're if
you have two sides of room destiny
destiny does see divisions here launched
but 80% walk to the
side of the room for a little while and
they wanted to check it out know if it's
it may depend on like you know who drops
first like what if Destiny's in February
and it's great does that set the bar
higher for division
what if division can get it out in
January and destiny set up for February
does that setup just need to be like oh
crap but here's the Danny boxes you
would have to assume that they'd even
get that long I'm just I'm just homo
from a division standpoint right you
know you have sat there in front row
watched all the mistakes of destiny -
yep you can't I mean when they came out
their whole mission was to initially get
destiny wanna kill destiny one initially
so now there's not all this data they
see what their community doesn't want
you know and let's be honest even though
I haven't been playing division since
division one much I've been watching
videos here in there and I know
comically will still play they've
tragically improved that game you know
from what it from their base from the
base now I'm hearing stuff you play D
winning and get something going to d2 so
my incoming in is like divisions coming
they're coming and they they have a lot
of ammunition and I think I'm worried
that even if destiny to is fantastic
revival you know what a new game does
right I mean it's there's no question
like something new a full sequel same
thing that's need to it had big numbers
like people ran out of it real quick but
whatever a full sequel it's gonna get
some attention mm-hmm so that's that's
not a I mean but yeah you're talking
about update 1.8 that was the big one
I'm not even gonna give a little bit
more but they took the overall game
world and they made like a high-ranked
version of that the same thing we talked
about for destiny make those Patrol
something they did that they took the
time and they put that into their game
they took content and they made and
these are the things that if they've if
they're smart nothing against Bungie
whether it was shortened schedule
couldn't have time to get all the
features in there and had to rework an
entire thing we don't know but there was
a lot that was learned for the first one
that was not brought into to that I
don't think if you be soft and massive
are smart they're not gonna make those
same mistakes they're gonna take
the stuff they learned in any bleep
package coming to the table yeah they've
got the playbook don't do it destiny -
dick watch it hit the fan and be like
okay so that didn't work we don't know
why we don't know what happened but I
mean they have so many teams working on
this thing - you've got massive Ubisoft
reflections Red Storm annecy Shanghai
Bucharest like that's one two three
that's six teams that's a lot of people
you picture so I mean just the idea of
the fact that you know they've got
they're going big I mean Rainbow six
look at what they did with siege they
took a game that launched poorly and now
honestly for competitive shooters it's
literally probably one of the top
perfect school
oh my god you just nailed it because to
me as much crap as Ubisoft gets they
listen to their community and they have
proven that they can turn franchises
around Assassin's Creed boom it had a
revival right you know look at Rainbow
six that's one of in my opinion one of
the greatest gaming turnarounds oh yeah
period you don't even was trash at lunch
and nobody's playing it they stuck with
it for years I was trying to win so
they've got the notes they've been
already fixing things his division 1
division 2 is common man I am very this
this announcement threw me for a loop a
little nervous very I don't know cuz
even if they don't drop this year and
they drop early 2019 you know you're
just chopping off spots where destiny to
is gonna have a chance to shine not it
doesn't have a lot of places to win it's
gotta be amazing like we know mm-hmm so
now goes back to last point and I know
I've been talking a lot which go no back
to dock him use his point that maybe
they can't wait that long it may have to
be all guns blazing summer like cuz you
know summers tend to be a little slower
you know I'm saying
everybody have to have all on Dictys you
got call of duty in October red dead and
locked oh but the vision on deck you
can't drop in that normal time for
except time you're not gonna get enough
time to shine if you push it back to the
early 2019 we assume divisions in that
that timeframe
interesting interesting hmm yeah I don't
know cuz I mean you look at there you
look at their roadmap though and there's
stuff that's like hey it's not even
gonna make it into one point two mods
will 2.0 is not gonna be in one point -
how much more time are they gonna have
you have May April so you've made June
July August you have three months and
then September is their typical time
frame can you fit everything you need
and doesn't need to to fix it by then
that's the point I mean I mean I know
those there's a world of crunch time I
don't I mean
Bungie developers they're probably not
gonna get paid enough for what comes in
the next like 60 working some long tough
hours trying and it's like and we know
we've set the bar high but it's like
there are just a lot of things that
we're in a game once that we wanted
again so there's never enough content
for most of the stuff we know that right
it's tough man it's tough I'm very
curious to see how the expansions play
out especially the one after expansion -
all right so we know expansion - is what
may or whatever fine you know but like
you said with all this stuff getting
delayed and you know we haven't even
talked about the rapid that's supposed
you know weaponry work that everybody
actually wants that with legitimately
bringing people back
they put specials and you know you know
the weapons laws yeah the weapon slots
tough placement that's a big deal I
looked at a little trust me there's a
lot of positive stuff about this one
point one point for that sort of more
positive than negative what I saw
negative stuff like you guys didn't
listen we told you we still don't want
yada-yada gotta fail you know about this
air box update and I'm just like still a
big point of contention you know it is
so I was like they they doubled down on
a new system yeah and it's like okay but
it was just like I mean it's just one of
those you're just like yeah that's the
bill and it's just like crap like you
gotta look back and go hey we double
down on this system whatever happened I
mean gee is there a point where it's
like hey put them under an NDA ask your
big peoples like do you think this is
gonna be like do you think this is gonna
be right and I there mmm let's just
let's just equate this to a relationship
they bet on the wrong girl
pretty much right they put all they say
you know what this is what we got to do
bigger and better casual the casuals it
was a nice little quick fling and
they've moved on down the core who would
still be loyal now they're disgruntled
because you cheated you don't have
enough time to get things right before
this other person comes into
relationship no it's trying to woo us we
know division is trying to divisions
whole intention was so they saw the
success of destiny one they Ruby wanted
to get a piece of that mmm oppai euro
sent an MMO like PI this relationship
was bad everybody what's our time and
then we got fortnight run around out
here you gotta Tendo ready to from to
have for a developer because more and
more there's so many good ones it's just
it's rough man but man for division no
like some of what I really enjoyed about
that is the deeper dive into stats and
things I mean some of it wasn't clear
like you know a vertical grip versus a
horse I'm like some of that stuff was a
little vague and again we like some
transparency but there were options to
be like hey there's a little more
there's different levels of guns and no
but there were things that were a
struggle and they need to work on fixing
it's like you know the dark zone was way
to trollee I mean I was that's terrible
the end game was not really there I mean
being
versions were not painful it was a room
that was just as rough like didn't so in
theory that's one but it was like we got
to see and that's where I still wonder
it's like do you throw that division in
New York
do you have it more like we need some
more diversity we need some more ass I
don't want to walk everywhere in New
York now oh god no yeah we get on the
bike a motorcycle I their bikes come on
now though still function right things
like that hopefully that would be like
you know your big pitch at e3 be like oh
yeah you got a motorcycle now or you got
it was just a bicycle just forward
movement that's a little faster than
jogging come on so but also it's like
you got to have an end game that keeps
them around because it isn't gonna be
just a box facts that that's the hurdle
division has to because as great it was
it was with the deep-diving the mid
maxing the gear as far as like they
really had great systems you know they
were doing emote they had emotes before
d2 gotta boats doesn't have the emot--
wheel exactly they had all the fast
travel they had a lot of innovative
things and just managing your character
interface wise was really cool so the
base stuff for the most part was there
they just need a little bit more in the
enemy variety you know because they went
so realistic yeah did that that was what
that was my problem with division as
well excuse me what it was was that it's
trying to be an MMO see why destiny
works is because it's fantasy it's space
fantasy and you're shooting these you
know powerful beings you can get away
with that if there's a guy with a hoodie
and you shoot him a thousand times and
there's a number nine going over his
head it takes you a little bit out of
that immersion yeah so it almost like
it's like they need kind of like zombies
or something like that so I think you're
making a great point about this and the
fact that there's still stuff they have
to prove and you know you now get me
down to reality which is that as great
as they have the mistakes of destiny too
but let's see what they do with that in
game let's see you know how to handle
stuff is the bullet sponges and stuff
like that those are problems that they
have well it's gonna be interesting man
I had to bring this I noticed slow along
with me but I had to bring this up yeah
no way I saw it too and I mean when I
started my channel that was literally it
started with destiny doing some stuff
and then one of my first little boost in
subs when I was like I did a giveaway
for the division and that's like I broke
a hundred subs because I was doing a
giveaway that was like one of the first
things on my channel I was doing so no I
mean I definitely got to come back and
talk about this one because it has
certain like that one to level 30 system
with really cool yes right away they had
the in-game lore with the Holograms s
sorry cause no I mean you had the side
mission you had the different tiers of
missions but they were all still tied
within the story mmm-hmm oh you had you
know you had your major events you had
to go do you had your side missions that
you would go do still in this open world
still running around in a place that
looked amazing by the way well
graphically looked fantastic
I finally because it was cheap on Steam
or something like like the whole gold
thing was 20 bucks or something I bought
it on my new PC looks immaculate like
Ubuntu version and destiny by each other
in PC mobile to pc games that look
amazing
yeah so take three years refine it these
things are gonna look and play awesome
just gotta see what the systems are yeah
man I'm very curious man I'm very
curious and I'm actually gonna touch the
you know I know they've had a couple of
days there was one expansion that I
really did like and we talked to so like
this division in flashpoint slash
division but um there was one survival
yes just like more grinding survival was
its truly its own thing that's what I
liked it oh you have to get the medicine
it you know you got to stay warm you
know I'm saying you have to really see
survival immersed me more yeah into that
universe continue no no I was gonna say
and that was why that's something to
wear
it didn't matter how much you grind it
what your level was if you want to go
into a game mode and level the playing
field you get to do that and we don't
get that option in destiny anywhere you
it's not just like so I mean Call of
Duty has a gun game for example you
start with a pistol kill you keep going
through the weapons but everybody has
the same experience skill will you know
kind of make you better through the
levels or you know you may be better at
knowing where to go and run and things
like that but you still all start at the
same place mm-hmm so something like that
where like you know give us a longer
mode give us something where you know
you have these like 12-minute PvP
matches but give us something where
there's more of a conquest a you know
king of the hill something and with a
decent larger set of players that's some
of the some of the modes that destiny ii
would love to have mmm for plays and
fireteam yeah no no but see like i mean
even if it's like uh even if it's four
players well four or three whatever even
it's a three person as like doc said
before make it like a nightfall world
run but i mean i know they're the worlds
they designed or no you know no question
but like you know make it a lot darker
make it harder to see make its where
you've gotta like you know stick
together to maybe like you know brighten
up an area and like work on finding
necks
give us a full mode that uses look uses
the air use you've got but in a
completely different way that is you
know say it's you have another vendor I
mean holidays in there and say it's like
hey this is like you know a scouting
type of pde conquest who knows but I
mean take those it's you know poor on
words right now sorry for everybody
who's listening what I mean something
like survival but have it go be like a
destiny version like you want to see
people try something differently yeah
yeah like so I mean survival was the big
one I didn't play last stand aside I'm
actually kiddin that well yeah I didn't
last anything yeah but I mean they took
something like underground it's like
they added a you know a completely
regenerating that's not I mean that was
cool
get it kill or repetitive for some and
yeah the gear was there and you know
there but there were some differences to
it but it was still they added a
completely unique thing to it
hmm absolutely prison of elders was
probably a similar version of that so
that's probably a fair comparison but be
in survival something like that would be
amazing in destiny I would love to see
that I would love to see it too man
and at the end of the day just to reel
all this back in you know as much as you
know I am fearful a destiny fan this is
still good and the reason why it's good
it's because destiny has no choice but
to step up its king well you're gonna
get swallowed up you're gonna get
swallowed up so they've gone I mean
obviously I don't envy the devs though
that they crunch like you said this
summer between now you know all the way
to 2017 this is a tremendous crunch for
them to see what they're gonna come up
with you know to try to get this
community all the way back but you know
there's gonna be some lines drawn in the
sand and one you know competition is
good as gamers we get the best out of it
Division is coming call of duty's coming
it's gonna be everybody falls out you
know and all of this and if destiny
actually can survive this or if not I
mean you think they'd do it III showing
for destiny - oh absolutely
like taking king - I mean do you think
they do that they're absolutely
absolutely because um tradition has
shown that III is activision treats III
very big that's these a huge IP they're
going to have a presence there and like
I said I'll be impacts as well in a
month make no mistake they can have a
presence there with that next DLC they
they use those big events to rivet one
thing about their marketing team here's
the hype train master I'll give Oh a
plus plus plus you know saying so I am
convinced that we will see something the
question will be what e3 is when the
timing do they stick to their guns of
their normal September release window
we'll see yeah it's gonna be that that's
gonna be real interesting if it says
that's September man I they just have so
much and things keep getting pushed
that's why it's like mods aren't gonna
be ready for Mays expansion that's
literally your big expansion
that's what you want to bring people
back for in mods aren't gonna be ready
for that mods and weapon rework right
weapon placement we work yeah you know
like oh that would be your time with
that expansion to like just try it like
hey we're gonna do this we're gonna have
this expansion we know most of you guys
like if you have the season pass already
have this we want our current player
base to try this stuff out and like you
know there may be and I wish there was a
way for them to even do it to her here's
a crucible playlist here's a crucible
playlist where we flipped everything on
its head give us a point list where
those weapon types are different
absolutely give us those brownies that
forces play different place if you want
us to use a damn grenade launcher so how
about somebody's face let's get our
strike we got those core thing and I'm
really leaning towards doc now so it's I
was like uh they may need to go faster I
just don't know if realistically they
can throw true and you know to your
point it needs to be done right so
there's a difference between rushing to
get something out and getting it done
right so that you'd actually we've seen
twice what rushing does to death yeah so
no I mean I mean right and I'm we've
we've all seen it we've seen destiny an
initial launch like the story got rushed
the story story was the big one it's
like what happened there's a lot of
vagaries which gave me a whole lot to
guess about and destiny to whatever this
whole 16-month if that's real it makes
sense because there's a lot that was
left out
so again rushing this game for people
who burn through and want to play it as
much as they can if it's not there right
I don't know but I was like but again
you have to ask answered Activision
shareholders it's like does Activision
take a hit to try and rebuild a friend
franchise unfortunately it's like I
don't know if they can take a hit could
call in duties not even the big
powerhouse that it was before and they
don't have another giant IP Blizzard
doesn't have a thing that can be like
hey we got Blizzard under us and you
know they're gonna release this new
thing that's gonna bump us while we work
on
none of that's there mmm I don't know we
may have probably taken up enough of
your time this morning a Long Point this
is completing like we got the go fast
update hopefully coming we'll get a feel
for what things are like mm man that far
out a holiday season of games play out
somebody ever gives me a real Pokemon on
switch that's a problem as well they
still got anything oh yeah this
Nintendo's getting the third parties in
there it's like stuff like you know
battlefield and destiny won't run on
there but I mean South Park stick of
truth I like the third party support on
that one that was actually cool to see
as well just a little shout-out to that
but that's not the vision to that was
yesterday I was like whoa what didn't
see that coming
no I mean yeah it blasts out of me I
didn't think they'd be ready to talk
about it so early so we well they they
didn't say much they're just like it
exists we'll talk to III it's like peace
three months we're like all right we're
gonna hide in our box again but to see
that makes a whole lot of people think
absolutely and that's gonna make people
judge what happens and destiny even more
to be like a like we got this thing
coming it's like am I really gonna buy
all these other things in destiny oh
you're just gonna wait have Red Dead
Redemption occupy me for a few months
and maybe check out division it's mean
competition is at a whole new level
right now if you're a gamer it's great
if you're a developer I don't envy you
brainy developer it's like Call of Duty
smart rock stars come and we need at
least a couple weeks otherwise we're
screwed it's like they know it they move
so that just takes that is weird when
you say that like it's October 12th when
does Call of Duty usually launch like
maybe November 12th like even a month
later typically like sometimes November
78 that first the end of that first week
of November sometimes gives them a
couple weeks and then you've got the
Black Friday and all that fun stuff so
when you turn around and so hopefully
you guys enjoy these flashpoints we do
we call it flash points just a nice name
for the chat and it's definitely still
gonna be you know somewhat Bunji focused
but if we you know get off base and
occasionally bring up other stuff I hope
you guys roll with us on those because
we're still gamers this is not our only
game and as we've told you guys before
if this isn't your thing right now
we're here to let you guys know when
it's good but if we're enjoying other
stuff we do like to talk about that as
well so hopefully you guys are a little
more open-minded sometimes and enjoy
some of these offshoots of discussion
appreciation to my man Chris Cobra and
easy rock with us
pretty much the entire flash me up on
Twitter so yeah they were in here and
these these are good talks man and just
just want to inform the community like
what's going on you know for the people
who still love the game you know what's
happened in the future and be honest
about it and that's why I love doing it
man it's really fun to do these new
devant is it's it's it's literally us at
Guardian con all over again
talking destiny for hours upon hours and
as you can see now it's just nerd out on
it even before and after on here we're
nerd out about other stuff like clothing
cars and we're people like the rest you
guys but we definitely enjoy that the
game is talk and I've been I mean I've
been a gamer since 8-bit Nintendo it's
just in my blood at this point it's in
my DNA so my brother's the same way and
his kids are gamers and he'll be play
monster 100 with him he's like yeah and
then we got a monster hunter it's like
I'll get beefed up so they can go play
and I was like it's it's we we enjoy
everybody so and I just want to think
everything that's important man and now
we get another one coming up next week
hopefully we'll see what's going on two
more mobs before the patch oh God 15th
and 22nd and bam 27th it's there so 1.4
yeah and then April got to start that
marketing train I think so mocking it's
right for a next expansion then we're
gonna be breaking down trailers frame by
frame
belike Alden let me click forward one
frame click here we go alright talk
about you do your outro there Loic
kognito here you can find me on twitter
at lord Cognito on xbox at lord Cognito
and playstation at Blake switch you
don't get social security pin number
we're not doing that before that one
just you know ask directly he's nice
about it you catch me and the rest of
the Lord's every Sunday iron Lords
podcast church will be in session
big big guest please catch us this
Sunday we're gonna have the United
States NPD video game analyst breaking
down numbers it's gonna be a huge hole
please show support that's gonna be on
the inner circle Network Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time Matt Chris
can tell them we'll be in the building
please if you have any questions about
how why your favorite game didn't sell
or your system you know we're gonna be
wrecking this thing that it's gonna be a
fun show it's a big show please support
also Saturday we're doing a monthly
thing with our Pratt should be a lords
of the arcades it's like a monthly show
kind of like a whole grizzled veteran
gamers just talking about the good old
days and what's going on now so catch
that I think that'll be Saturday at 6
p.m. on a brats channel I believe
basement radio arcade podcast and yeah
that's all I got man and well you know
we gonna be back in the building next
week next uh these Friday morning again
right we're gonna keep it Friday we keep
that a for now guys just kind of my work
schedule so me Friday morning Thursday
night it just kinda depends on work but
Friday for a while I think get up and
you know get a good sleep have a good
chat feeling fresh for you on the other
side you're about to go crash but I like
baby in beat in DD Wow can't talk
I have a question seriously and I'm sure
it's probably something already just I'd
be curious for NPD in their track
how much the digital world has changed
what their numbers they get access to
how much you know if they feel like hey
these sales aren't here but we know
digital is there but we don't get access
because some companies don't at least
some or whatever like that's kind of my
big one for NPD like how much does
digital come into play how much do they
have access to and how much does it you
know what's the swing looking like is
digital be an even bigger that's that's
mine for yes salutely I'll definitely
try to put that in for you man
absolutely chapman usually just like oh
yeah but I was like but no I was like I
do try sometimes to get in there and or
at least if nothing else I try and catch
it later so if I'm not there I'll try to
catch it later I'll try to get your
questions so pretty much a digital game
question I got you yeah so just about
you know kind of digital downloads and
all that it's like it's a different
world now so I'm kind of curious what
that does for them a bonta's basically
everywhere so Twitter its Ibanez
eb o NT is twitch.tv slash yvonne tests
always streaming these live he's got it
on the google I've got it on Twitch so
and then I'll get this on to my youtube
channel as well and then right there on
YouTube guys like if you guys enjoy
these always leave comments on either
channel check both of ammount like I
mean iron Lords does awesome stuff
they're discussions they get heated they
got a whole bunch of personalities in
that you got a lot of fun of me we got
we got passionate about this one you got
you got some we've got some
personalities those are awesome so
definitely check them out on Sundays
guys or subscribe and give you something
to listen to during the week if you got
YouTube bread's it's a good one to
download and listen to it while you're
doing other stuff because it is mostly
audio but I mean come on check that one
out it's all check it out man show some
support appreciate it but as always guys
you know me hit that like if you enjoy
these subscribe leave a comment below
honestly if you made it to the end leave
a comment just saying hey you know nice
shot thanks keep it going and if you got
questions for us leave them we want to
answer them for you guys because we'd
love to get some engagement know what
you guys are what are your thoughts like
do you guys think it's got to be
September I gotta get it soon or you
guys like I don't care if it's September
of 2019 just take a year off and do it
right like I want to see the extremes I
want to season
the division is looming we need feedback
yeah they're a pretty similar wheelhouse
so you gotta know what's going on but
yep so as always guys good afternoon
good morning or good evening to everyone
around the world and I say around the
world because I've actually checked out
my YouTube analytics and I've seen
people look at my videos from like 80
different countries which is insane it's
so cool it's honestly really cool known
that so where have you guys are at
around the world different time
different place different continent have
a good one guys
- peace